it's ten o'clock in the morning in
Argentina and the question everyone has
is how much is the dollar today
Argentina is in the middle of an
economic crisis and it's the US dollar
that in the spotlight once again the
ammonia crises in Argentina are cyclical
and things happen again
Argentina's look at the dollar and
people want to save themselves instead
of the country in general in the past
year recession is everywhere even though
the National money is the peso it's the
US currency what runs the economy the
main reason is inflation because a raise
in the value of the US dollar
immediately translates to a race in the
price of almost everything in the early
20th century Argentina was one of the
richest countries in the world thanks to
the export of beef wheat and other farm
goods but things change in the 1930s
because of the Great Depression in the
United States and political instability
and since then Argentina has defaulted
on its sovereign debt several times an
inflation has almost always been in the
double digit this Museums shows how the
Argentine currency has depreciated over
the years and in a way it explains why
Argentines prefer to save in u.s.
dollars the world crisis and devaluation
appears repeatedly in the coin museum of
when Osiris over the years Argentina has
not been able to solve its main problem
the economy needs dollars to grow but
the country spends more than it produces
so it needs to borrow abroad that's what
President Macri did since taking office
in 2015 Mac administration when they
took over the expectation was to
generate capital inflows and generate
growth through investment and
what happened you had a lot of portfolio
inflows but not as much investment Macri
was a bit too optimistic I took too long
to adjust the fiscal issues you had to
keep interest rates too high for too
long
and people already now mistrust the
value of the pieces and that's why
people have been going to the banks to
either buy dollars or get their money
out the u.s. dollar is not only used by
the elite in Argentina but by all
sectors that run to buy dollars as soon
as they have some cash it's how people
try to preserve their cash calls to
dollarized the economy are common in
Argentina but people like Mariana Lucy
say it will not work out well in 1991
and 2001 there was an attempt to tie the
peso to the dollar it was a
convertibility at that time it was not a
dollarization but the states did not
have a monetary policy a controlled
inflation but it devastated the economy
too he tended in the massive crisis in
2001 the next few months will be
difficult ones for Argentina that is
unable to amend an economic pattern that
repeats itself over and over again very
Tsavo al Jazeera bone Osiris